Ryan Gosling's tribute to his late dog
George is the sweetest thing you'll hear
all day he's uh was a good friend to me
the la-la-land star went on Ellen Friday
where he opened up about losing his 17
year old dog in December so was an
important lesson
the a-lister still wears his best
friends tags around his neck
that's George I love that and last
Saturday he wore a shirt with his furry
pals face on it while hosting Saturday
Night Live Gosling fondly recalled how
George traveled with him when he was on
set he also admitted that George was
more of a gentleman than a four-legged
animal I think he felt like being a dog
was beneath him and if that wasn't cute
enough
he compared George's look to an aging
rock star she was sort of skinny fat and
that big hair and you know no teeth open
sores but this isn't the first time
Gosselin wrecked us with his cute puppy
talk back in 2011 he brought george with
him to meet Jimmy Fallon that's George
hey George oh oh very good
okay George thanks for saying hi you
look like the apples
[Music]